a devastating emotional gut Punch or
laugh out loud Blockbuster Adventure why
can't it be both Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 is guessing mixed reactions but
they all say the same thing
with the arrival of director Peyton
reads Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
the fifth phase of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe officially kicked off it wasn't
the strongest star to say the least with
the film struggling to gain much
positive momentum with moviegoers
instead getting picked apart by many
fans and critics alike throughout his
theatrical run thank you Spider-Man
nevertheless it wasn't enough to derail
the MCU machine which has officially
launched its next Silver Screen title
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. courtesy
of director and DC Studios figurehead
James Gunn at this point the titular
team is in an odd spot the original
Gamora is dead though a version of her
from 2014 exists in the modern day
following the events of Avengers end
game since she doesn't remember him
Peter Quill has made it his mission to
find her and romantically sweep her off
her feet like before the new film also
focuses on the origins of Rocket Raccoon
while introducing new threads such as
the high evolutionary and Adam Warlock
after years of waiting Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 is finally here but what did
MCU fans think of it as some of the
earliest public screenings of Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 concluded many folks
took to Twitter to share their initial
thoughts on the Three core for the most
part fans agreed that it's exactly what
the MCU needs at this point in time one
person commented Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 is the first breath of fresh
air in a very long while for Marvel
that's a sentiment that many others also
expressed in tweets of their own another
fan made the Bold claim that it's the
best MCU movie since 2021 Spider-Man no
way home and yet another person decided
to call it now with the release of
volume 3 in their eyes the Guardians of
the Galaxy Trilogy is the strongest Trio
of movies to Gracie MCU the main
consensus seems to be that volume 3 is a
return to form for Marvel Studios and
the solid ends to the Guardians of the
Galaxy Trilogy there's also a lot of
love for the fact that Rocket Raccoon
takes a spotlight for much of the story
finally some fans praise the sequel
soundtrack which is packed with hits
from across different eras at the same
time as entertaining A musically
pleasing as Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 may be it's not all sunshine and
rainbows according to tons of Twitter
users the MCU film is an immensely
emotional experience as one for the user
wrote volume 3 just constantly rips your
heart out and puts it through a meat
grinder before putting it back together
with a rather wholesome and emotionally
acceptable ending that's certainly a
graphic and thought-provoking assessment
but it seems to be an accurate one all
the same another user stated that it may
have caused them to cry more than any
other movie they'd seen before while one
person admitted that they straight up
ugly cried during the film kiss your
mama that face but don't let the threat
of a few gut-wrenching scenes hold you
back another Twitter user stated that
there's an underlying level of joy to
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. all in
all audiences agree that it's a very fun
cinematic ride one that doesn't squander
its use of the mcu's very first F-bomb
something Marvel Studios had Kevin feige
apparently tried very hard to avoid okay
now what open the door Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is now playing so what are
you waiting for get in the car and head
to your nearest theater
foreign